[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur le plateau d' europe hebdo
que pèse l'europe dans la mondialisation
comment se positionne-t-elle et bien
c'est le thème de cette édition
consacrée à la campagne européenne
quatre invités sont avec nous mike hayes
rennes jean jour vous êtes candidate à
ces élections européennes
troisième sur la liste la république en
marche et vous vous présenter pour la
première fois en face de vous l'aura
slimani bonjour alors vous êtes
candidate sur la liste du printemps
européen emmenée par benoît hamon pour
le mouvement génération et vous êtes élu
municipal à rouen à vos côtés pierre
henri dumont bonjour vous êtes député
national si je puis dire députés les
républicains du pas de calais et en face
de vous votre collègue du pas de calais
ludovic pajot bonjour député
rassemblement national l'union
européenne s'est elle bien adapté ou pas
à la mondialisation c'est le thème de ce
débat c'est parti pour 30 minutes
[Musique]
et pour commencer cette émission je vous
propose de revenir sur une décision de
la commission européenne qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue c'était il ya environ
trois mois bruxelles mettait son veto à
la fusion annoncée d' alstom et siemens
au nom du respect des règles européennes
de concurrence
retour sur cette décision avec mathieu
des moulins on en parle juste après
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un divorce prononcé
avant même le mariage celui du français
alstom et de l'allemand siemens
les deux géants du ferroviaire
souhaitait fusionner pour tenir tête à
leurs concurrents chinois crr ces deux
fois plus gros que mais le 6 février
dernier la commission européenne met son
veto au regroupement
craignant une situation de quasi
monopole l'entreprise issue de la fusion
serait devenue de loin le plus grand
acteur en europe et sur certains marchés
de la signalisation
il n'y aurait plus de concurrence pour
être clair c'est bien d'être gros ce
n'est pas le problème ici mais nous
savons que les autres entreprises du
secteur n'aurait plus été en mesure de
rivaliser avec la nouvelle entreprise
née de cette fusion
le traité sur le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne confère a lieu la
compétence exclusive d'établir les
règles de concurrence sont donc
interdits les abus de position dominante
certaines ententes et concentration
ainsi que les aides de l'état sous peine
de sanction des règles très strictes qui
empêche l'union européenne de s'imposer
face aux grandes puissances selon cet
économiste
si nous européens pour des raisons de
concurrence nounou ligue au thon les
mains si nous ne permettons pas
l'irruption de grands chantiers
européens
alors on sera progressivement
marginalisé c'est pourquoi il faut
revoir la conception que nous avons des
concentrations intra-européennes le
rejet d'une fusion par la commission
européenne reste toutefois un événement
exceptionnel depuis 1990 pour 6400
fusion autorisée bruxelles en a bloqué
une trentaine
on
alors est ce que la commission
européenne en prenant cette décision qui
a fait grand bruit à l'époque a joué
pour les intérêts européens ont au
contraire contre les intérêts européens
à ce que ça vous a choqué cette décision
cette décision effectivement à choquer
de manière générale l'opinion publique
et les français et les européens parce
que comme ça a été dit à très juste
titre dans votre reportage nous
n'arrivons pas à faire émerger des
géants européens dans le cadre de cette
politique de concurrence
vous avez rappelé tous les contrôles de
cette politique de concurrence sur les
aides d'état sur les ententes sur l'abus
de position dominante
on a vu la nécessité qu'elle soit à
l'échelle de l'union européenne parce
que sur l'abus de position dominante
quand l'union européenne inflige une
amende à google ou à mastercard la bonne
échelle c'est l'union européenne mais
sur le contrôle des concentrations
effectivement là il ya une vraie
nécessité de faire évoluer cette
politique de concurrence pour mettre en
place des géants européens mais deux
équipages ou est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette analyse
moi je pense je crois au droit de
souverains des états de mener des
politiques commerciales afin de
développer des champions européens face
à des géants mondiaux
mais dans le cas précis d'alstom faut
savoir qu alstom c'est une entreprise
française qui ont dans le domaine
ferroviaire à 8 ans de carnet de danse
on dans son carnet de commandes pour 40
milliards d'euros donc c'est une
entreprise qui fonctionne bien et il ya
un risque avec la fusion d'alstom et
siemens d'absorption par siemens dastum
donjon s'est apprécié contre moi je lui
en suis contre la fusion d'alstom et de
siemens parce que ashton c'est une
entreprise française c'est un fleuron
dans notre pays
est ce important de préserver les
intérêts de notre pays
pierre henri dumont quelle est votre
position des études chez les
républicains du pas de calais la
question c'est savoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est arrivé à ce projet de fusion
entre siemens et alstom on arrivé là
parce que alstom est une entreprise qui
a déjà été sauvé une première fois en
2004 par nicolas sarkozy et qui
symbolise l'échec des manuels macron
échec quand il était ministre de
françois hollande parce qu'il a
totalement sacrifier la branche énergie
qui l'a vendue à de général elektriks
donc aux américains et que donc alstom
n'était plus assez puissant seul pour
pouvoir affronter sur sa branche
constante la branche transport
l'ensemble de la concurrence mondiale
donc en effet on est obligé maintenant
de voir un projet de fusion qui en
réalité n'est plus une fusion ou une
absorption
d'alstom par siemens et donc on n'est
plus dans ce système de partenariat qui
était à la base et donc au final nous ce
qu'on pense chez les républicains
c'est que dans les secteurs où le marché
est mondial il faut assouplir le droit
de la concurrence aux pommes celica rang
dans ce secteur là dans ce secteur là
parce qu'on fait face aux chinois mais
quand on est dans des secteurs où les
marchés sont davantage régionaux ou
nationaux
il faut rendre plus restrictive la
politique de la concurrence est ce que
le race les manies donc que vous êtes
sur la liste du printemps européen est
ce que la commission européenne n'a fait
qu'appliquer les règles ou est ce que
c'est bien là c'est que qu'elle a agi
comme institution technocratique alors
que bien sûr c'est un enjeu politique et
stratégique majeur donc elle est restée
dans son rôle finalement suis d'accord
pour le dire
bah pas vraiment puisqu'elle est censée
quand même être une émanation politique
des institutions européennes donc elle
s'est fondée sur les traités sur les
rays
mais moi ce que je veux simplement dire
c'est qu'évidemment aujourd'hui il faut
considérer le marché mondial quand on
regarde ces fusions acquisitions ça a
été dit déjà mais moi je partage je
partage cela et notamment sur la
question du ferroviaire qui est quand
même fondamental si on veut faire la
transition écologique plutôt de se
battre sur la question de l'automobile
on en parlera peut-être mais il me
semble que investir à l'échelle
européenne politiquement et
financièrement dans cette industrie
ferroviaire
c'est fondamental mais surtout à l'heure
où enfin il faudrait pas qu'on soit les
derniers eurobéats fin européens
libéraux bea
pardon de la politique commerciale à
l'échelle à l'échelle internationale
puisque les états unis la chine la
russie aujourd'hui les états
investissent massivement dans des géants
économiques et nous en fait on se rend
se restreint nous mêmes donc nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est d'assumer le fait
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe doit être une
puissance commerciale mais ça implique
aussi qu'à l'échelle européenne elle
soit cohérente d'un point de vue fiscal
alors qu'ils soient logistique c'est
parce que tous aient tous ces règles lui
lient les mains
elle ne s'embarrasse pas allen elle
s'emballe et c'est vrai qu'il faut de
certaines également que la fois d'une
édition regarde le marché mondial et non
pas européen quand on regarde ces
questions de concentration lyderic san
jose aux états justement pour ça que
mojix je crois ordre souverain des états
définir une politique commerciale pour
définir des politiques face à des géants
mondiaux et on a c'est vrai aujourd'hui
cette mondialisation qui est là mais il
faut que les états coopèrent entre eux
pour justement faire face à cette
mondialisation sauvage et cette
concurrence déloyale comment fait-on
pour répondre à prévoir ce qui vient est
petit en fait stratégique cg c'est
exactement l'inversé parce que si on
reste à l'échelle des états on voit que
justement on ne peut pas peser sur le
marché international sur la scène
mondiale
oui mais il n'aurait on attendait a ses
règles et street hier en pêche à des
géants de 2,2 de prendre deux de naître
et me oui mais c'est justement si on
reste sur l'union européenne aujourd'hui
vous dites en tant que nationaliste et
il faut rester dans nos petites
frontières et non pas du tout à la
réalisation on est une question on a un
vrai problème de taille c'est à dire
qu'il faut abandonner regarder la
réalité en face la france et 66 millions
d'habitants nulman c1 ou moins 80 s qui
ont des croissances démographiques
on a face à nous des géants comme la
chine aujourd'hui qui font plus d'un
milliard deux meilleurs 3 d'habitants on
a l'un d'eux qui arrive avec une
population et l'armée galecki sans doute
demain simplement qu'ils s'en fassent
pas le moment donné il faut être parfait
de la réalise un grand club mais je pas
dit le contraire on a des technologies
on a des ingénieurs on a des ouvriers
qui travaillent dur mais un problème de
taille on a juste un problème d'échelle
et qu' il faut être parfaitement
réaliste il faut qu'on ait une
coopération entre les différents pays
européens et parfois sur certains
secteurs il faut que ce soit beaucoup
plus intégrée sur des entreprises
européennes comme ça peut être le cas
sur airbus par exemple à windsor est
extrêmement bien là iront alors sur
serre sur l'aéronautique où ça peut être
un peu moins le cas en intégration mais
avec des coopérations renforcées en
dehors d'autres secteurs si c'est
l'échelle pertinente mais évidemment se
replier chacun dans notre coin non mais
c'est pas dix ans en dix ans comme le
propose le rassemblement national que
ont lieu chez nous avec nos
qualifications internes au pays on va
forcément se faire bouffer par la
mondialisation qui vient des états unis
du brésil de la russie de la chine ou
l'inde c'est évident ce qu'on veut c'est
des coopérations aujourd'hui on a une
union européenne avec une concurrence
des lois déloyales aux siens au sein de
l'union européenne avec les embête un
des travailleurs la pression fiscale et
des tomates espagnoles qui viennent sur
les étals des marchés qui sont 30% moins
cher que les les commet
l'échelle en dehors de l'union
européenne avec les traités de
libre-échange le ceta le mercosur qui
menacent notre voiture sortant aussi des
traités vous êtes pour renégocier les
traités aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit que
cette union européenne nuit aux intérêts
de nos compatriotes laura c'est en fait
on voit bien là tout l'écueil dd2 des
nationalistes et du rassemblement
national mais aussi de toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ne font pas ce qui doit
être fait pour harmoniser socialement et
fiscalement par le haut les l'union
européenne pour qu'elle puisse être
réellement cette puissance démocratique
sociale écologique qui peut signifier
qu'on nous vend 6 nationales gênant
justement mais justement oui ça fait des
années que ce match entre les libéraux
et les socialistes nous les socialistes
je suis dans ma partie qui est aux côtés
de me savuth habilité on descendra
connaissance nationale qui lui a tenu
tête effectivement à la commission
européenne quand il quand elle a
souhaité imposer des mesures d'austérité
en grèce sans l'aval démocratique de son
peuple
donc voilà j'ai pas de leçon à recevoir
là dessus mais ensuite qui peut croire
aujourd'hui que ce que finalement si on
revenait sur des frontières nationales y
aurait pas de la concurrence entre
l'espagne la france l'allemagne la suède
bien sûr qu'ils en auraient elles
continueraient cette concurrence coach
virtuel avec la chine et l'inde à
hauteur de nos standards effet être un
modèle aussi à l'échelle internationale
nous voyons que les propositions qui
sont faites pour la rassemblement
national ne répondront pas aux objectifs
monsieur je vous remercie donc ne
répondront pas aux objectifs de d'une
concurrence saine à l'échelle
internationale par ailleurs nos
standards environnementaux sociaux
économiques sont les plus élevés sur les
noisettes pour les réserves et ifs mais
bien plus que ça il faut les imposer il
faut que dans toute notre politique
internationale et pour agir sur la
mondialisation pour porter des standards
plus haut à cette échelle il nous faut
imposer aussi ses standards le respect
de standards aux autres acteurs à la
chine aux états unis et alors justement
pourtant marqué un peu donne certains ne
s'embarrasse pas avec les règles
n'hésite pas à rétablir des mesures
protectionnistes quand les intérêts
nationaux sont en jeu c'est ce qu'a fait
donald trump et garneau en décidant de
taxer l'aluminium et l'acier venus
d'europe mais l'union européenne n'est
pas forcément rancunière puisque
bruxelles a reçu un mandat des
dirigeants européens
pour élaborer un futur accord commercial
avec les états unis explications en
images vert de l'union européenne
après des mois de tensions diplomatiques
les européens sont prêts à ouvrir des
négociations commerciales avec les états
unis
je vais maintenant prendre contact avec
nos partenaires américains pour
organiser une première session dès que
possible
la décision a été prise par une majorité
écrasante de dirigeants européens à
l'exception de la belgique qui s'est
abstenu et sans le vote de la france
paris refuse de négocier avec un
partenaire qui s'est retiré de l'accord
de paris sur le climat je ne suis pas
favorable à ce que nous nous lancions
dans la négociation d'un vaste accord
commercial à la manière du type parce
que le contexte ne le permet pas
le futur accord prévoit une baisse des
droits de douane sur certains produits
il sera limité à l'industrie
l'agriculture les services ou les
marchés publics devrait être exclus de
la négociation
je ne suis pas favorable à ce que nous
incluons en aucun cas l'agriculture dans
ces discussions et je considère qu aucun
standard européen ne doit être supprimée
ou à baisser en matière environnementale
en matière sanitaire en matière
alimentaire par exemple pourquoi parce
que c' est le principe même de cette
europe souveraine à laquelle je crois
l'union européenne veut éviter la guerre
commerciale avec washington après un an
de haute tension avec donald trump
le président américain a imposé des
taxes sur les importations d'aluminium
et d'acier
ils menacent aujourd'hui le secteur
automobile européen sujet sensible pour
berlin et la commission européenne veut
faire vite
elle espère un accord avant la fin du
mandat de jean claude juncker le 31
octobre prochain
alors thierry henry démone question
prouver ce que vous êtes globalement
favorable à l'ouverture de ces
négociations commerciales avec les états
unis qui a été avalisé le 15 avril
dernier un peu en toute discrétion d'air
aux républicains on n'est pas opposée
par nature à des accords commerciaux
entre les grandes puissances
simplement il faut déjà voir d'où
doué lahoud ou par la france sur ce
point emmanuel macron nous a été
présenté comme étant celui qui allait
diriger l'europe prendre le lead dans
l'union européenne on va sur cette
question qu'il est parfaitement isolé
parce que sa position est intenable sur
les questions environnementales et que
la proposition des républicains
une des nombreuses propositions qu'on
peut faire dans cette mathy dans cette
matière sur la question environnementale
justement et de dire qu' on doit mettre
des barrières à l'entrée des produits
qui viennent de l'extérieur de l'europe
sur le marché intérieur de tous ceux qui
respectent pas les critères
environnementaux c'est à dire que c'est
très bien de dire une forme de tasse et
c'est une forme
la france est une forme c'est une forme
c'est une forme en effet protectionnisme
environnemental on peut appeler ça comme
moi mais ça permet surtout de protéger
le marché interne européen le marché
intérieur des attaques contre le climat
contre l'environnement menée par nos
concurrents qui font du dumping
environnemental et qui ne s'embarrasse
pas de pouvoir nous importer nous
envoyer des produits qui sont des
produits qui ne respectent aucune norme
enfin je suis désolé mais quand on on
est dans un dans un système où on va
taxer les automobilistes français dans
ma circonscription du pas de calais qui
fait 10 km et qui fait son plein
d'essence pour aller travailler
alors que à côté le produit qui a été
recueillie en france le produit agricole
qui est cueilli en france qui va se
faire transformer en chine ou en inde et
qui revient en france qui fait des
dizaines de milliers de kilomètres lui
n'est pas taxée à la même hauteur que
les 10 km fait par le petit ouvrier
français
il ya quand même un sujet quelque part
et c'est une des propositions phare du
programme les républicains alors marie
pierre bedel la position d' emmanuel
macron de la france du général
il disait qu'il était allé contre elle
était contre l'ouverture des
négociations mais il a beau il a eu beau
parler dire et réitéré son opposition
non la france ne sera pas entendue
puisque ces négociations sont quand même
ouverte il suffit d'une décision à la
majorité qualifiée ce que ça vous choque
que qu'on ne prenne pas en compte la
position de la france qui est
globalement contre l'ouverture des mains
font de ces négociations alors déjà pour
rebondir sur ce qui vient d'être dit sur
les accords commerciaux dans leur
globalité
moi je constate déjà une chose s'avère
les votations elles n'ont globalement je
pense surtout les accords commerciaux à
la grève actuelle au parlement européen
c'est quand même le parti populaire
européen qui aussi votent
majoritairement ces accords
déjà je pense que c'est important de
leur appel vous futures batailles par
ailleurs bon je suis désolé quand on
prend des parlementaires tels que jean
arthuis qui soutient manuel macro s'est
toujours opposée à ces accords et il ya
d'autres exemples
donc s'il vous plaît je vous remercie
donc sur l'ouverture du mandat de
négociation effectivement c'est un
mandat à la majorité qualifiée emmanuel
macron a porté le projet auquel nos
croyances c'est à dire que nous ne
négocions pas avec les états unis tant
qu'ils sont en dehors de l'état qui n'a
pas été entendu
effectivement c'est à la majorité
qualifiée moi je note aussi par rapport
à une autre chose et c'est là où on
verra l'évolution la nouvelle zélande
qui elle aussi souhaite inscrire dans
des futurs accords commerciaux
cette clause nécessaire que il n'y aura
pas de mandat de négociation si des
états sont en dehors de l'accord de
paris donc oui nous avons été mis en
minorité en guinée bien évidemment mais
c'est à dire que de prendre cette
position est d'être fort sur cette
position est de ne rien céder
nous arriverons à convaincre nos
partenaires sur les états unis
l'objectif est aussi de faire en sorte
que les marchés publics on le voit bien
dans les accords commerciaux
nous avons ouvert ne marche le public
contrairement à ses autres aux et chine
0 etats-unis 30% donc l'ami européenne
est la première puissance commerciale
nous sommes en capacité de pouvoir
négocier avec les états unis et avec
d'autres nous devons dont les treks
beaucoup plus uni pour pouvoir négocier
est ce que nous porte le rassemblement
national c'est justement cette désunion
donc nous n'arriverons pas à exposer et
à exiger nos standards ci alors nous y
allons vous répondrais l'iddri doivent
jouer une seule gamme reyl aux racines
une certaine ambiguïté l'union
européenne
augmenter les droits de douane pour
riposter face aux états unis d'un autre
côté à ouvrir des accords commerciaux
avec les états unis
ensuite concernant les traités
libre-échange rappelé dominique riquet
qui surréaliste en marche a voté les
traités libre échange et à une
déclaration du ministre brésilien de la
culture du 8 mai qui dit que la france
n'offre plus de blocages sur des
concessions sensible dans le secteur
agricole pour ouvrir les frontières de
lieux aux produits de sud-américains
dont je vais vous poser la question est
ce que vous êtes pour le traité libre
échange avec le mercosur qui fait qu'on
va importer des produits qui viennent du
brésil où notre pays
de la viande bovine notamment alors que
nous mêmes nos agriculteurs font de la
qualité et que ces produits qui viennent
de l'autre bout du monde ne respecte pas
les maintenant sanitaire que ce que
pourrissent nos agriculteurs et sa
menace
évidemment les producteurs de viande
dans notre pays donc est ce que vous
êtes pour sur le mercosur l'objectif est
d'imposer nos standards notamment sur
les sur ces sujets imposés aussi la
question du principe de précaution pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que justement des
produits qui ne respectent pas nos
standards ne rentre pas sur le marché
intérieur mais pour l'instant ils
devront être nombreux mâles massif c'est
finalement négociations concernant le
transfert de cela le même débat qu'on
voit par là on va dire entre les rues m
haies et les nationales vous vous dites
quoi vous dites quoi
mais nous on dit qu'il faut assumer
aujourd'hui à l'heure du réchauffement
climatique de la concurrence libre et
non faussée entre l'ensemble des
salariés du monde une forme de
démondialisation et de relocalisation de
l'économie à l'échelle européenne bien
sûr mais pas à l'échelle nationale ça
n'aurait aucun sens et donc nous sommes
pour une part un ajustement carbone aux
frontières donc le fait de faire payer
la compensation du surcoût
environnementale par exemple aujourd'hui
vous produisez une tonne d'acier en
europe
elle vous coûte l à-peu-près le produit
deux tonnes de co2 en chine elle en
produit 3 sans compter le coût du
transport
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça madame que
vous pouvez dire qu emmanuel macron à
une position écologique mais en même
temps il n'a pas permis de réouvrir il
n'a pas mis la pression à arcelormittal
pour réouvrir les fourneaux d'ailleurs
alors que c'était ce qui était prévu
dans l'accord qui lie et arcelormittal
khalid à l'état donc ça veut bien dire
que cette position c'est un deux poids
deux mesures qui l'a finalement par
rapport à l'environnement et donc aussi
d'avoir une clause sociale protectrice
pour les salariés européens pour qu'ils
ne soient pas en concurrence de manière
déloyale par rapport à des salariés
chine mais il faudrait la ligne 1 6% un
domaine dans lequel il faut de
l'unanimité et on est loin même de la
voix ans mais nous nous souhaitons que
mais la france elle peut bloquer un
accord commercial
le parlement européen et les
institutions elles donnent un mandat de
négociation mais l'accord il doit bien
sûr et d'un an chinois le parlement est
évidemment il faudra que cet accord soit
refusée mais nous le dire en l'échelle
européenne puisque on est sur un débat
européen
on souhaite que nous nos députés en tout
cas s'opposeront à ces accords
commerciaux parce qu'encore une fois
c'est pas uniquement une question
stratégique
c'est aussi une question
environnementale et de quel modèle on
veut et qui bénéficie cette
mondialisation aujourd'hui en europe il
ya de plus en plus de milliardaires qui
sont de plus en plus riche et toujours
autant de personnes voire
plus de personnes qui dorment dans la
rue donc la question du modèle
économique s'est pas uniquement des
débats stratosphérique c'est aussi à qui
ça bénéficie aujourd'hui ça ne bénéficie
pas aux citoyennes et aux citoyens
européens et nous c'est ça quand l'ordre
est au coeur de notre politique
économique et commercial andré dumont
sont extrêmement claires nous on explose
explique dans le programme qu'il faut
avoir une double compétence sur ces
accords commerciaux d'une compétence
européenne évidemment mais que les
parlements nationaux puissent aussi
également pouvoir donner leur ont leur
mot à dire si et quand on parlait du
ceta tout à l'heure le fait que le
gouvernement la majorité des manuels
macron refuse d'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour du parlement français une
évaluation le stade les accords de
libre-échange avec le canada
ça nous pose un problème vous pouvez pas
venir ici en nous disant que les
parlements doivent avoir leur mot à dire
et en même temps que la majorité que
vous représentez et sur laquelle vous
êtes pour laquelle vous êtes candidate
aux élections européennes refusent
d'inscrire seul à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale
deuxièmement sur le mercosur le mandat
qui était donné par les pays membres de
l'union européenne à la commission pour
négocier un mandat qui a quasiment 10
ans et donc nous ce qu'on demande c'est
avant d'entamer une quelconque
négociation qu'on puisse réaffirmé un
nouveau mandat avec des standards
extrêmement haut beaucoup plus haut que
ce qui avait été fait auparavant
on prend le ceta par exemple on voit que
ça bénéficie en très grande majorité à
nos agriculteurs et qu'en réalité jean
les appellations telles que ça se fait
je termine monsieur pajot tels que ça se
fait actuellement
nos agriculteurs exporte beaucoup
plusieurs le canada que on importe
depuis le canal j'ai visité des fermes
au québec et à cela quelques mois il ya
que cinq fermes au québec qui sont en
capacité d'exporter des produits en
france donc il faut qu'on sorte des
fantasmes et justement le fait
d'inscrire cela au parlement nous
permettra de sortir de ses fantasmes et
le dernier point j'aimerais bien savoir
comment est ce que vous allez faire avec
vos alliés au niveau des libéraux au
parlement européen puisque ce sont eux
qui sont vos alliés naturels monsieur
fair fiat est là
la commissaire en charge de la
concurrence car nous allions faire du
bon pain sont pas du tout les mêmes que
celles complètement nos alliés au
parlement européen me madam sont ceux
qui sont les plus favorables à des
accords qui ont le moins de deux aspects
environnementaux qui sont le moins
restrictif et qui sont les moins
protecteur pour nos industries
vous avez un double langage qui est un
langage qui est ici à paris un autre
langage qui est à bruxelles avec vos
alliés naturels qui eux sont pour une
concurrence qui est totalement libre
malheureusement qui va se faire au
détriment s inscrire est ce que tout le
monde n'a pas un peu ce double discours
en impression car discours ici et un
discours pour bruxelles un peu au sein
de tous les partis
au nom de nos parlementaires ont
toujours voté contre les accords de
libre-échange qu'il s'agisse du du
taffetas qui du coup a été abandonné et
du ceta mais surtout notre député
européen edouard martin a fait voter
l'ajustement carbone aux frontières aux
parlementaires mais un certain nombre de
mesures pour justement protéger les
travailleurs européens de cette
mondialisation qui aujourd'hui ne leur
bénéficie pas et encore une fois je veux
remettre l'humain au coeur de nos
discussions à la fois et et la nature et
il faut que l'europe soit cette force là
mais ça n'est pas uniquement des grands
discours madame c'est aussi les actes je
ralentis ses parts dans les grands
discours avant et je suis dans l'action
et justement c'est ce que je mets votre
gouvernement ne l'est pas et donc il
faut aussi méritent ouverte à qui parler
du c'est armées hia on parle pas des
risques sanitaires pour les
consommateurs aussi notamment d'importer
du boeuf avec des antibiotiques du
canada en france alors que nous c'est
pas autorisé par le sénateur il fonda
ken hill folie non mais sur pajot
évidemment non nocere avec m et moi j'ai
discuté avec beaucoup d'acteurs qui
s'inquiètent justement dosée bien sûr
mais est ce que vous êtes et l'eau est
traitée libre échange nous proposons
c'est un remplacer le libre-échange par
les us juste échange c'est à dire
concilier le commerce mondial avec des
exigences sanitaires sociales et
environnementales c'est en ça que vous
allez c'est l'équateur au parlement
européen contre l'ajustement carbone aux
frontières
on a voté contre cet été des méchants
mais je vous parlais du localisme
mais localement nationale vous avez
contre cet ajustement carbone aux
frontières donc c'est quand il y en a
assez de ce green washing permanent
devrait parler du localisme au niveau
européen et ensuite avec notamment des
fraises espagnoles ou des tomates
espagnoles qui viennent sur les étals de
nos marchés vous à concurrencer son
produit vous êtes pour la conversion
totale au bio de la pac monsieur remet
pour le bio mais elles sont pas bien de
notre engagement qui est traité
des problèmes des pesticides on va
rester sur le thème de ce débat je vous
écoute et tout de suite les points de
vue d'autres candidats à ces élections
européennes
florian philippot françois asselineau et
nathalie arthaud ils sont interrogés par
alice rougerie et nathalie guille mois
nous en sommes à se poser la question
toujours en termes de rivalités de de
concurrence il faut se protéger
un des ces salles capitalisme
capitalisme c'est la jungle c'est la
guerre voilà la guerre économique la
guerre commerciale puylagarde tout court
aussi souvent parce que cette guerre
militaire cette guerre physique qu'elle
est le prolongement en fait de toutes
ces rivalités là et bien moi c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis
révolutionnaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle brèche ce combat cette société
capitaliste qui est fondée sur 20 sur ce
marché sur cette concurrence sur cette
compétition permanente walla et l'union
européenne nous préserve pas du tout ça
le jeu du capitalisme mondial des
grandes entreprises des grandes
entreprises mondiales n'a aucun rapport
avec le périmètre de l'union européenne
il faut qu'on ait des coopérations moi
je me réjouis qu'on ait des coopération
avec la chine avec le japon avec
l'allemagne avec l'algérie avec le monde
de demain
il suffit de regarder ce qu'est le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est un monde
interconnexion généralisée dans le monde
faut être conscient de ses intérêts
c'est beaucoup plus puissant et efficace
que d'être gros avec des intérêts
divergents entre les polonais les
allemands les français les italiens on
n'a pas les mêmes intérêts et donc ça
fonctionne pas et donc quand on est
conscient de ses intérêts on l'effort la
france est très forte parce qu'elle est
présente dans le monde entier
donc moi ce que je vous dis je
répondrais c'est se souvenir qu'on a la
francophonie qu'on a un espace maritime
de 11 millions de kilomètres carrés
énorme deuxième du monde et qu'on à
l'outre-mer partout et ça c'est une
force
avoir un projet mondial en misant sur
nos forces
alors on a bien compris vous aviez des
positions quand même assez différente
sur certains points évoqués dans cette
émission mais je vous propose pour finir
ce qui nous reste très peu de temps de
me citer une mesure phare du programme
de la république en marche qui
permettrait à l'union européenne de
lutter à armes égales face aux géants
mondiaux
marie pierre védrine sur 7 sur ce sujet
plus spécifiquement la mesure phare que
l'on souhaite porter c'est l'inscription
d'une directive éthique vis-à-vis des
entreprises c'est à dire que des
entreprises des multinationales qui ne
respectent pas
nos standards en américaine chinoise
quelle nationalité si elle ne respecte
pas à nos standards elles ne pourront
pas rentrer sur le marché intérieur
nous devons mettre fin à cette naïveté
et exigé la réciprocité
on l'évoqué tout à l'heure aussi sur les
marchés publics et il faut justement
refonder cette politique commerciale
avec l'inscription de nos règles mesure
phare l'une avec l'ajout du
rassemblement national pour passer de du
libre échange en elias et destructeur de
l'europe on le voit aujourd'hui un juste
échange avec de l'arrêt précité de la
responsabilité vis-à-vis des engagements
environnementaux
un exemple les etats-unis ont imposé au
mexique un taux horaire dans les accords
commerciaux donc voilà c'est important
de passer de ce libre échange naïf à un
juste échange et d aussi renégocier les
traités de libre échange qui aujourd'hui
menace notre notre agriculture
théoriquement pour les républicains
nous on pense que face aux produits
étrangers il faut admettre une double
préférence une préférence européenne et
française comme le font les américains
que le buy american act que des belges
achètent des avions de chasse aux
etats-unis et pas en france est purement
scandaleux on veut également créer un
nouveau droit qui permet de réserver 50
% des marchés publics aux entreprises
locales particulièrement les pme ce qui
est actuellement le cas dans la
législation européenne et enfin on
désire imposer la stricte réciprocité
dans les écoles internationaux à savoir
qu' un pays qui accepte pas d'importer
nos produits ne peut pas envoyer ses
propres produits sont marché ce me
semble parfaitement pertinent avec un
point de vigilance extrêmement important
sur les questions d investissement
d'instructeurs dans les secteurs
stratégiques pardon par exemple il y a
l'intelligence artificielle on peut pas
laisser la chine construire l'ensemble
de nos infrastructures ça peut pas
fonctionner comme ça le mot de la fin
pour vous lors au sli danoise lady jane
asie mais l'ajustement carbone aux
frontières et la protection des
travailleurs sur les questions sociales
par rapport à la concurrence déloyale
dont ils sont donc ils subissent
aujourd'hui elle est fondamentale mais
nous nous la défendrons avec des
parlementaires qui la défendent pour
certains déjà est fortement au parlement
européen et qui ne feront pas l'envers
de ce pourquoi ils ont été élus parce
que là j'ai l'impression qu'on est tous
d'accord mais la réalité ce sont les
actes et nous ses actes mais
construisons aussi à l'échelle
internationale notamment avec alexandra
occasio cortese avec bernie sanders avec
yannis varoufakis parce que y aura pas
de solution à tout cela sans coopération
pour le coup à l'échelle internationale
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission spéciale
d'europe hebdo vous retrouver la semaine
prochaine
oriane
mende signé avec quatre autres invités
je vous souhaite une très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
ciao
[Musique]